let's hear what this guy's saying maybe
he'll he'll help us out
all right gang hope everyone as well and
that chin is still alive
i'm just out here join the british
countries out with my pooch hello
i've got a question for you guys the
queen chikinga or di stinger
my opinion is sting the [ __ ] get a real
job
i want to know what your thoughts over
the usa and whether you actually like
that wrinkly
first trap also chapala here's a lot of
interest over in manchester for your
sauce so i hope you're bringing that
sauce out internationally
oh let me know what you guys think gang
gang
chi chitty bang bang bang bang bang
right on okay
the royal family is weird to me man
they're still doing the damn thing
it's getting weirder it's almost like
become a reality show that they won't
discontinue kind of yeah it's like
season
13 and we're just like come on dude when
this shit's gonna end
and then her son was hanging out with
[ __ ] your boy epstein
really oh yeah big time then did the
interview like a
dumb ass oh yeah and it was he looked so
guilty
wait what you don't see any of the songs
dude
you know there's the things you know in
the things you don't blow my mind and
i'm an
idiot yeah i'm stupid as well but i know
some of this [ __ ]
it just uh yeah man the queen i look i
think it's a it's a it's like a
tradition you know it's like a tradition
it's like
it's like a christmas tree it's like
halloween really
the other thing is is this con if we had
sam triple and eddie bravo in here they
tell you they think she's the richest
person on earth
wow really yeah they think she runs
everything but then
how old is she 107 or something there's
some tradition that i like though i feel
like if you get rid of all tradition
then
everything's going to be a bit boring
they're like the white kardashians
though they're like the original
kardashians 100
like you know what what she is what the
royal family is no different than what
we did to the kardashians yeah
they're they're famous for no reason
yeah oh but they're but
everyone looks up to him everyone wants
to know every detail and everything
like she's not making any policies or
[ __ ] passing any bills or laws
yeah wow and there's our boy dirt nasty
right there and they offered him one
time
70k to say he hooked up with meghan
markle to say he did
and he wouldn't do it he went he went to
dinner with her and then
the tabloids wanted him to say they did
more after
really yeah i wouldn't have taken that
and he wouldn't do it good for him
legend legend legend and he took her on
a date
you know another legend move she's
pretty smoking married a prince
yeah yep married to prince man so i'm
going to say
what's his guys he's always talking
about that oh the royal family
i think it's kind of cool yeah i thought
there was a king
and he was like real mean like henry
they like cutting heads on now that's
what we need
yeah get a real king up there you got
right now your boy boris fat
johnson yeah also covet alumni
oh yeah i like now i like forest man
but boris looks a little bit sometimes
like too much like uh
who's that horse looks like the the
lewis capaldi the singer
no but he also looks like the brother of
the
who's the thick chick off of um perfect
pitch
rebel wilson looks like rebel wilson's
shitty
brother yeah yes yeah like reb
wilson yeah yeah boris definitely
rebel rebel wilson boris also looks like
louis capaldi's uh dad
you know yeah a little bit and louis
capaldi can [ __ ] sing
oh he can't i've never heard of him oh
how do you [ __ ]
sing oh yeah now i gotta look into it
yeah well rebel listen lost some way i'm
talking about old school rebel wilson
i'm talking about wendy's rebel wilson
lewis capaldi looks like every character
from harry potter in one person also
they all mix yeah which is pretty pretty
powerful pretty charming pretty
remarkable
talented guy super talented but here's
the thing man what are we talking about
[ __ ] oh king of the singing yeah here's
what we need we need real kings that are
willing to
get a dragon get a castle chop your head
off kill somebody yeah chop your head
off
have a night you know castle where's
where's the big fluffy red velvet
rug yeah if you're gonna be a king play
it up yeah dude
too many people are being kings but not
doing [ __ ] yeah take [ __ ]
over take countries over yeah why is why
is pitbull acting more like a king
than the actual king of england you know
worldwide
or the prince of england and where's the
damn king he died
well [ __ ] you got to get another king
how long has it been to have a king no
wonder they're screwing around over
there
you know it's frustrating it just pisses
me off
because they are the original keepers
man so if they can't even get a king
they're milling around under this female
under this you know she's a charming
woman but
you know unless she's a real savage
grandmother she's outlived her husband
68 years
jeeps how old is she
uh she king george was her man huh
yeah so that's the thing man yeah i'm
with you though get a dragon dude
yeah get a [ __ ] 94. damn
and then there's that prince uh queen
elizabeth
she can't stop won't stop don't stop at
all wow y'all slept on that queen a
little bit
[Music]
is